this is the sky news weekly business
roundup i'm AME kerbal bringing you the
big business stories from the past seven
days BP shares slump has a federal judge
ruled the oil group is grossly negligent
over the Gulf of Mexico disaster euro
shock the single currency slide after a
surprise move by the European Central
Bank and Ukraine peace dividend shares
jump on hopes Moscow and Kiev can put an
end to the bloody conflict BP could be
forced to pay out billions more in fines
over the 2010 Gulf of Mexico disaster
this week a judge found that the company
acted with gross negligence in the
biggest oil spill in US history the
ruling means BP could be liable for
penalties of up to 18 billion dollars
under the Clean Water Act when you
actually look at what the judges said in
his ruling the reason that he feels that
BP was grossly negligent he focuses on a
crucial test that the company did at the
Macondo well on that the date of on the
date of the disaster April the 20s 2010
and what happened was this was a test
essentially meant to check whether or
not it was safe to move away from the
well to detach the rig from the well and
go off and do another job in a shock
move the european central bank cut its
key interest rate to almost zero at the
same time the eurozone central bank
announced fresh measures aimed at
shoring up the region's ailing economy
the ECB's main interest rate now stands
at a record low of 0.05 percent it also
cut its deposit rate banks will have to
pay just 0.2 percent to have funds held
by the ECB other than the fact that the
eurozone still slowing down inflation
still surprising down on the downside
and probably the least controversial
measure was cut rates again and although
they didn't really say it one of the
objectives is to keep the euro on a
weakening trend the bloody conflict in
eastern Ukraine continued this week with
reports of heavy artillery fire even as
the ceasefire was set to start shares in
the Moscow stock exchange the my sex
lepton the hope of an ending and
meanwhile a world away the threat of
more sanctions against Russia was at a
heart of the NATO summit in Cardiff
those Ukrainians gathered in London for
a business summit were keen to emphasise
that country is still an attractive
investment obviously one has to remember
that Ukraine is a large country and
whilst obviously there are problems in
the East there is still the most
expensive country which is not affected
by military action and indeed life
continues as usual that's almost all
we've got time for but before I go my
favorite story of the week the future is
floral once more the fickle world of
fashion the once snubbed the feminine
and floaty designs of laura ashley is
looking kindly on the retailer once more
the 61 year old company has struggled in
recent years but sort of fifteen percent
rise in pre-tax profits for the half
year to July like many other retailers
profits have been boosted by online
sales will that it for this week's
business round up with me Naomi kerbal
for more on those stories and more check
out sky news com or the sky news for
iPad app and do get in touch via Twitter
with your business stories I'm at Sky NK
tweets and the team is at Sky News Bears
you